patti chiari amicizia lunga si sente
troppo giovani non guardate questo video
siete ancora in tempo piuttosto ecco
fatemi un favore
guardatevi una puntata dei papi gacha
tutti allora si sta avvicinando
halloween e celebrare questa giornata ho
pensato di condividere con voi alcune
delle esperienze più traumatiche che ho
vissuto quando ero piccolo i traumi che
ti seguono smettere di interagire col
mondo o iniziare a postare video dove
diversi della donna il trauma più grande
che abbia mai vissuto quando ero piccolo
è la morte della mamma di bambi
paragonabile solo a quella di muffa sa
solo che può in qualche modo louisville
e mele vivente lui vive insieme a vive
in tutti diventa una specie dei temi
imberbe intestinale arrivano timon e
pumbaa dublino quello col culo rosso che
tipo reclama codici fiscali quindi anche
sticazzi che morto bambini è diverso la
madre di bam diviene seccata all'inizio
di un film che poi è pure una merda
quella vera mazzata bambin con trans e
quella che il mario tifosi che io
asfalterà e tutti quanti con una
mietitrebbiatrice e poi diventa grande
un barbone fine bella merci siete delle
neomamme e volete far vedere i bambi ai
vostri figli
voi vi meritate gli assistenti sociali
in casa bambi e un film da far guardare
per punizione cioè come quell'altra
tragedia del buon dumbo cumbo che bene
bull issato perché alle orecchie grandi
e poi c'è quella scena traccia tragedia
tragedia pure c'è la mamma che con la
proboscide lo culla da oltre le sbarre
con la scena quella di dove di lui si
ubriaca al circo e di colpo incominciate
degli elefanti rose diventa questa
specie di linsday lohan strafà fai da te
di vostro figlio preferirà un clistere
di senape anzi walt disney se stai
guardando questo video hai fatto tante
cose belle nella vita ma se ti trovi
all'inferno è per bambino piante non ha
scritto ma in uno dei gironi infernali
li proietta nel loop un altro trauma
enorme per me è stato satana
forse il futuro farò un video
nel quale parlerò di tutto ciò però fate
conto che venendo da una famiglia molto
religiosa dove praticamente per merenda
mia mamma invece di darmi il killer guai
non mi dava direttamente localisti a
ogni volta quando lo so qualcosa di
sbagliato per me uno stupro la parte di
satana era la cosa più ovvia io ho
passato notti insonni a fissare il
soffitto questi occhi da lemure
aspettando che satana venisse facesse
scempio della mia anima
vi dico solo che ho imparato l'ave maria
il latino perché per me la rosa più
efficace contro i demoni è un ex facto
patronum pazzesco io un miracolo se non
sono diventato un cannibale altro trauma
terribile è stato perdere il mio
migliore amico che lo diramate molto
qualcuno di attaccarlo non mi sono perso
un quadrante dell'orologio per diventare
l'ho trovato come sorpresina del mulino
bianco cioè questi orologi contanti
quadranti diversi e dentro a questo qua
c'era un alieno che facevi pure ok e
galleggiava in questa cupola piena di
liquido amniotico
devo io mi sentivo triste lo guardavo e
lui capito stava sempre mi facevano va
tutto bene ok se il meglio storia di una
solitudine un giorno stava questa sagra
di paese ed era non mi ricordo perché
ero un po triste allora me lo faccio
abbasso lo sguardo per guardare
l'orologio e me l'ero perso ragazze
credo di aver versato qualcosa tipo
sette chili di lacrime ricordo che lo
cercavo in giro e non riuscivo a vedere
perché era tutto quanto sott'acqua me
sembrava il titanic un altro trauma
enorme per me è stato tutti quando ho
scoperto che quella bella canarina dove
c'è simpatica in realtà è un maschio io
mi ricordo mi sono dovuto mettere sul
pavimento tipo di scarafaggio morto con
le gambe insomma perché alle ciglia sa
che nei cartoni le ciglia ce l'hanno
solo le donne e soprattutto perché i
ragazzi c'è quella voce dal muco
ma poi perché se il maschio mettete
nelle magliette delle coatte fatte di
paillettes
ora sto diventando tv un trans fobico
domani vedono l'affaire family day
ho trovato il mio costume da halloween
mi travesto da sentinella in piedi
zarate non volevo offendere suona
sentinelle in piedi non amo attaccare
ovviamente le persone non sono una
sentinella in piedi comunque questi sono
alcuni traumi che mi hanno reso la
persona orribile che sono oggi vivo
ragazzi fatemi sapere qua sotto dei
commenti quali sono quelle cose che vi
hanno bloccato la crescita o comunque
reso dei cimiteri di gioia io vi
abbraccio di sostengo sempre e
ricordatevi ad halloween se volete
veramente farmi cagare sottosti temi la
madre di bandi ciao
se ci sei batti un altro colpo